what if Aaron won the final battle
completed the rumbling and became king
of the world that is the ending that
many people would have preferred to the
ending that we got but what would this
new ending actually mean for the story
and its characters what would king Aaron
do next let's talk about it right now if
you guys enjoy my content here on the
channel leave a quick like and comment
for that YouTube algorithm and if you
want to help this channel attain its
final Titan form by hitting 2 million
subscribers do me a big favor and
subscribe right now we are so close Okay
I'm going to assume that all of you guys
know the original Ending by now
especially since it finally aired in the
anime the anime did expand on the ending
and make it better and I did an entire
video breaking down the anime ending and
how it differs from the manga so I will
link that in the description if you want
a detailed play-by-play here I want to
jump right into the scenario in which
the rumbling doesn't stop when 80% of
humanity outside of the island of
paradise is wiped out instead Aaron goes
all the way and wipes out 100% of
humanity outside the island Aaron
Remains the makavelian badass that he
became during the whole jarist and
rumbling Saga and after the rumbling
concludes he returns to Paradise to rule
as King in order to unlock this
alternate ending we have to change some
of the events that take place in the
final Arc of the story now we don't want
to change Aaron's character completely
so we have to assume that he still wants
to protect his friends and loved ones as
much as possible after all that is why
he initiated the rumbling in the first
place he didn't do it because he enjoyed
killing all of those people he did it
because he felt that it was the only way
to prevent the island from being
annihilated by an international military
Alliance people sometimes forget that
prior to the rumbling Paradise was about
to be attacked and invaded by a massive
International military force everyone
Aaron loved and cared about would have
been killed just because the world saw
the eldians on the island as Devils it
didn't matter whether the people on the
island actually did anything wrong it
didn't matter if they were innocent
children they were all about to be
destroyed and their destruction was
imminent Aaron tried traveling to marlay
in order to make peace but the peace
Mission failed the other nations didn't
want peace they wanted to completely
annihilate paradise and everyone on it
now in the original ending Aaron doesn't
want to take away the freedom of his
friends including the Titan Shifters and
the acement and so he allows them to
keep their powers and to try to stop him
even though it's clear that after
activating the founding Titan power
Aaron does have the ability to Simply
take their powers away from them in this
alternate scenario Aaron still wants to
protect friends but he doesn't
prioritize their freedom he simply
strips them of their powers as soon as
he activates the rumbling making it
virtually impossible for them to
actually stop him they might still try
to get on that plane and stop him
somehow but if they do Aaron might take
further action for example he could
affect their physiology in other ways or
even mess with their memories in order
to prevent them from ever leaving the
island alternatively he could
communicate directly with flock and the
aorists and just instruct them to
incapacitate the plane and all the ships
immediately keeping all of his friends
trapped on the island and away from the
rumbling is the best way to make sure
they survive so if Aaron is completely
focused on keeping them safe and
finishing the rumbling and he doesn't
care about their freedom forcing them to
stay on Paradise is the best course of
action Aaron then successfully carries
out the rumbling and destroys 100% of
humanity outside of paradise now to be
fair small groups of humans could still
survive if they fly over the rumbling in
an Airship or hide deep beneath the
Earth such as in really deep underground
mines or caves but even if these small
groups survive everything on the surface
will be destroyed and it will take
centuries for these small groups of
survivors to create a new civilization
from scratch so okay after Aaron
completes the rumbling what does he do
next as we know his top priority is to
ensure the safety of his friends and
loved ones and to protect Paradise You
could argue that by completing the
rumbling Aaron has achieved that goal
and now he can do whatever he wants he
could pick some random part of the world
and live there alone until the curse
ofor claims his life life and he could
even bring Mikasa there with him and
live out his final days together with
her in complete isolation in some ways
Aaron would finally be free free in the
way he fantasized about as a kid when he
and Armen talked about a vast endless
World beyond the walls a world where
Humanity had gone extinct in this
fantasy world there was no need to worry
about rivalry conflict or jealousy
because no one else was there but in
this scenario we are creating freedom is
not Aaron's priority yes he has
eliminated the outside threat to
Paradise but human nature being what it
is there are plenty of internal threats
to the island even back when all of
Humanity on parades believed that they
were the only humans left in the world
and even when they all had a common
enemy in the form of the Titans there
was still internal conflict on the
island there was a repressive government
a brutal secret police there were people
who opposed the government and so on now
that a common external enemy is gone the
people are likely to form factions and
turn on each other the Jager ists might
go go too far and abuse their power the
old Elite might Strike Back Against The
aorists even more factions could emerge
and so on so the only way for Aaron to
ensure peace on the island is to return
to paradise and to rule as its king most
of the people there would see Aaron as
the hero who saved them from imminent
destruction and since he has the power
of the founder he would be looked upon
as a sort of God King who must be obeyed
the jarist would be 100% on board with
his Rule and if he chose to marry into
the old royal family by taking Historia
as his wife he would also gain the
support of the old royalist Elites who
still resent the rise of the jurists but
realistically he could still hold on to
power fairly easily even without
involving Historia so he could
technically still marry Mikasa I know
that all of you Mikasa and Aaron
shippers would appreciate that and
believe me I am one of you that said for
all the support he would have if he
completed the rumbling while leaving all
the shifters and Levi and mikas as
stranded on the island he would be
greatly resented by them he destroyed
the families of the Marans he Dishonored
Levi and he broke mikasa's heart he
would also be resented by any foreigners
still on that island including kiomi and
her people onanon yelen and so on now to
be honest I think that Mikasa would
definitely come around eventually
because she loves Aaron although if
Aaron chose to marry Historia and
abandon Mikasa then she would probably
remain angry with him Aaron could choose
to just live with the Potential Threat
of these guys possibly retaliating in
the future or he could take steps to
deal with them now we already said that
he wants to protect his friends he can't
just kill them but he could potentially
manipulate their memories he could make
them forget what he did or mess with
their memories in some other way in
order to keep them from trying to
retaliate against him in the future
again he is definitely taking away their
freedom if he does this but in this
scenario he already did that before so
he's not too worried about doing it
again if it means keeping everyone on
the island safe Aaron could even go a
step further and bring the story full
circle by erasing everyone's memory of
the rumbling and who was responsible for
it basically everyone would just think
that humanity went extinct outside the
island for all they knew it could have
happened a thousand years ago and that
is just the way things are it's
literally what everyone on the island
thought at the beginning of the story
only this time the fact that there are
no humans on the outside is actually
true and not just a lie made up by King
Carl Fritz Aaron obviously can't live
forever founding Titan or no founding
Titan so he can't keep the peace on
Paradise permanently even if he could
somehow use emir's power to eliminate
the curse of imir he would still will
die of old age eventually if Aaron's
priority is long-term safety and
stability then his best bet is to create
a hereditary monarchical system where
the current King will prepare his
children from birth to become rulers and
to inherit the founding Titan power
hereditary monarchies are certainly not
the most free or Democratic political
systems but historically they've proven
to be the most stable just as the Roman
and Byzantine Empires so if the goal is
long-term stability then Aaron becomes
king creates a new Jagger Royal Dynasty
and prepares his descendants to rule for
decades and centuries to come we do
still have the question of whether any
sort of memory manipulation would even
work on the acans because as a minority
bloodline they were immune to Carl
Fritz's decision to erase the memories
of all eldians on the island however
Aron did demonstrate the ability to
affect Mikasa and Levi through the paths
so maybe the fact that he has imir Fritz
actively supporting him means that he
can bypass the minority bloodline
limitation otherwise he would have to
somehow pacify the remaining acement l
both of them maybe by buying them some
more scarves now these what if scenarios
are a lot of fun to think about however
we have to remember that all of this
speculation is based on the premise that
Aaron could still convince Emir to lend
him her power even if the rumbling went
in a different direction the final
chapters of the story imply that Emir
only agreed to help Aaron because he
promised to free her from her servitude
to her late husband King Fritz in the
end Aaron was able to free air through
Mikasa more specifically when imir saw
that Mikasa was willing to go against
Aaron and kill him even though she loved
him because she was doing it for the
greater good of humanity imir realized
that she could do the same she could
defy the will of King Fritz for the
greater good even though she still loved
him if Mikasa is not there to stop the
rumbling and if she doesn't kill Aaron
then imir is not freed in some ways she
continues to serve King Prince's will
which is now embodied within the will of
King Aaron jger the new king of eldia
since Emir is not freed then Titan
powers of course remain unless Aaron can
find some way to erase Titan Powers
altogether with emir's hell if he did
this he would of course be taking away
his own power and so he is also reducing
his own ability to ensure peace and
stability on the island if the curse
ofir remains then characters like Aaron
Riner Armen Annie Peak and Falco are all
destined for an early grave as I
mentioned earlier maybe with the power
of air on his side Aaron can find some
sort of solution to the curse like maybe
he can modify the bodies of all the
shifters including himself in order to
make them immune to the curses effects
but that is of course pure speculation
there is also the possibility that Aaron
could make himself live longer even
without removing the curse and that is
by sealing himself inside a crystal like
the one that Annie used this would allow
him to stay alive longer and emerge only
in times of Crisis to bring everyone in
line in case civil conflict or something
along those lines occurs even with the
crystal his time would run out
eventually but he would have a lot more
time to prepare a successor and ensure
that the transition happens smoothly
this would mean that Aaron can't even
enjoy the little time that he has left
but that is the sacrifice he must make
for the sake of his friends and everyone
else on the island since he's already
sacrificed the rest of humanity for this
cause it isn't hard to imagine him
sacrificing even more all of this
speculation also assumes that the events
that occurred in the original ending of
Attack on Titan weren't predestined and
inevitable in his conversation with
Armen in the end Aaron makes it pretty
clear that everything that happened was
destined to happen and that he couldn't
change it no matter how hard he tried
this is made even more explicit in the
anime ending than in the manga our
alternate scenario in which Aaron
becomes king of the world rests on the
assumption that yes Aaron could actively
decide what happens he wasn't a pawn of
Destiny and his mind wasn't being warped
by the founding Titan based on what
Aaron says to Armen there is some
question about the state of Aaron's mind
once he begins to experience the past
present and future as one and the same
within the founding Titan if he sees the
past present and future as the same
thing then how can he change the future
to him the future has already happened
so how does he change what already is
I'm not going to get into the
metaphysics of all this but I just
wanted to bring it up as something to
think about but okay let's say Aaron can
win he does win and he becomes king what
ultimately happened to the island and I
don't mean just after Aaron but even
hundreds of years later unless the
founding Titan power exercises
totalitarian control over the population
at all times I think we pretty much get
the same ending as in the original there
will be relative peace for some time
perhaps even centuries but eventually
human nature will do what human nature
does and there will be war and conflict
even with the rest of humanity wiped out
Humanity on the island can still find a
way to fight among themselves the island
of paradise is roughly based on the
island of Madagascar in our own world
and Madagascar is considered to be the
fourth largest island in the world if
Paradise is of a similar size then there
is plenty of room there for say Southern
parades to try to break away from
northern Paradise or for the jerus to go
to war against some rival political
faction for all we know that apocalyptic
war that happens at the very end of the
story could have been a civil war so I
think that that if Titan powers are
somehow removed from the world in the
future or if the founding Titan power is
not being used in a blatantly
totalitarian way by the king then some
kind of internal conflict is inevitable
that is just what the history of our own
world teaches us and this is the exact
lesson that attack on Titan has been
trying to convey from the very beginning
unfortunately human nature being what it
is war and conflict are inevitable they
can be delayed but they can never be
completely avoided thankfully Humanity
is resilient and even in the hardest of
circumstances humans find a way to
survive that is exactly what we see in
the very end when that child and dog are
seen walking through the
post-apocalyptic landscape proving that
even after that destructive future War
some people did survive and continue to
live on the island of paradise okay tell
me right now and be honest which ending
do you prefer the original or the ending
where Aaron wins and becomes king of the
world do you think things would have
turned out different L if Aaron chose
this path or do you think that in the
end we will get a massive war no matter
what let me know down in the comments if
you're looking for an epic Attack on
Titan video to watch next check out my
full breakdown of the new anime ending
link on screen and in the description if
you guys enjoyed this video and you want
to see more Attack on Titan content in
the future leave a quick like to let me
know and if you want to help this
channel attain its final Titan form by
reaching 2 million subscribers do me a
huge favor and subscribe right now we
are almost there